what's going on guys welcome to the 33rd
ever
episode of the iced coffee hour so far
you have made twenty eight thousand nine
hundred and forty dollars
fantastic amazing very good thank you
thank you thank you
chandler smith everybody thank you i'm
excited to be here yeah how many rental
properties do you own now
um so 114 units of rental real estate
and then a 73 unit storage complex
wow now when you say units how many
properties is that like if we break it
down for profit
it's a lot of duplexes and four plexes a
32-plex a 24-plex and eight-plex
um yeah i think it's like 11 4-plexes
and
four duplexes or something like that at
what point do you lose count
i think when i hit 100 i stopped
counting property numbers 100 units
is silly because it was one property
that put me over that but
i like units because it sounds bigger
wow and how long did it take you to
accumulate
that many it's been eight years
eight years have you exponentially got
more
as the time has gone yeah yeah like
first year
it probably can't even count because i
like invested in a property
and then pulled the money out and then
got a condo and then a duplex and then a
four-plex and then
it just got bigger and bigger every year
so how did you do that what were you
doing before real estate
so it all came from door-to-door sales
honestly when i was
21 years old i couldn't find a job
applied everywhere
and somebody said hey come knock doors
and sell pest control
so i went out and in three months i
ended up breaking the rookie record
so i made 96 000 just knock indoors
selling pest control
was that kevin who did door knocking
with you yeah it was i remember that
video
wow that was with you yeah meet kevin
guys
uh it was this was in idaho wasn't it so
yeah originally he came to idaho to talk
about it and look at my properties
but then like six months later we had
him come out to san diego and we knocked
doors in san diego
selling pest control yep wow imagine
that now imagine
going online finding out about your
stimulus check and be like wait a second
this is the guy
he tried to sell me pest control seven
months ago look at it
that's crazy okay so you're doing
door-to-door sales and then
then what happened so you won the
lottery yeah and then you invested in
real estate
97 000 your first year doing that yeah
just 96 000.
and is that common in that field or is
it like it it actually is
so our average guy makes between 25 and
30 000
that's like where the average is but our
top sales rep
this year made over three hundred
thousand dollars just selling pest
control
door-to-door so door-to-door yeah wow so
and that's just
like still selling essentially the way
that it works is if you're a good sales
rep then you can manage a team so
first year i just sold the next year i
managed a team where i trained everyone
how to do what i had done
so that year i made 144 000 the next
year i made just shy of 250 000
and then it's just kind of scaled so now
i manage over 300
sales reps um this year we actually did
over 15 million
in sales just with my people in that
four month period
so you're still making money yeah from
selling past
that's more and more every year wow what
how do you
oh i feel like we have so many questions
i want to keep going on this
do you have any musicians open yes first
question always
www.elitesummersales.com
wow how do you train somebody what makes
them a good salesperson can you tell
so from meeting somebody if they're
gonna be good at sales you can tell
um to an extent i tell everyone if
you're gonna be a good sales rep it's a
combination of being able to work hard
crazy hours being able to handle
rejection and then being able to stay
positive through the first two because a
lot of people come out they have this
skill set
but then after getting you know 10 f
bombs in a row
they're like all right this isn't for me
so if you can stay positive through that
we train you every on everything so pair
of verbals non-verbal verbal
communication
body language everything you can imagine
we show you what to say how to say it
and if you put in the time like it's
just that you show up
it's a plug and play system and if you
do it we tell you you're a great sales
rep what sort of hours do you have to
work to to do that so we start at 9 00
a.m
we do 45 minutes of training in the
morning
and then you work until dark with an
hour break for lunch so you do that
monday through friday
saturday you work till four and then
sunday you have off so are you an
employee
if you have to take an hour lunch and it
works or an hour your setup is a 1099.
yeah
so you can do what you want to do that
works out great too because
you've got a bunch more write-offs right
so
wow yeah and this is based in idaho
falls
so it's not really based there we're
nationwide we're actually the eighth
largest pest control company in the
united states
and so this year i had sales reps in san
diego
in houston in dallas in san antonio um
in nashville and in atlanta that makes
sense because i figured if you guys were
clearing 15 million dollars in revenue
i was like that everyone in idaho falls
must have passed
there's like 80 000 people in idaho
falls we don't even have an office there
we're just in the bigger cities
got it why door to door why not online
target these people
phones yeah um it's a funny question
i think for me i couldn't find another
job and i said you could make good money
doing that
however i don't think anybody else is
putting on the number of accounts that
we are
doing at door-to-door if you've got a
sales rep that's trained properly
you can just reach so many more people
and you've got a rep that's there to
close them
and it's a decision where with the right
push people need it
and they buy it and so i mean we
it's not broken so you know why fix it
wow i think this year we did 20 000
accounts
online um and we did don't quote me on
this but like
three or four hundred thousand accounts
as a company i make up about
um nine to ten percent of the whole
company that i work for so i'm one of
you know 10 guys like me that manage
groups of themselves wow
that's incredible so within just what
how long has that been since starting
within 10 years now you do 10 of your
sales
yeah yeah it's well that's the thing is
when i started we only had 400 sales
reps now we've got
2500 to 3 000 depending on where we end
up
this next summer so why couldn't you
have taken equity in the company i feel
like at that level they
must have have they offered you a
percentage ownership
yeah yeah so um and i don't
i guess we can share this but we have
something called ltip
and every account essentially gives you
a portion of ownership
and we are planning on either going
public or selling a portion of the
company in the next five years i think
our owner wants to hit
a billion dollars before doing that yeah
um
but with the amount of l-tip points i
have if we're able to sell for a billion
i'll have
a 10 to 15 million dollar payout from
that l tip
so that's wow for the next couple years
that's crazy
so why then real estate and then why
then
youtube after that yeah and also
everyone um
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
smith okay let's get him to a hundred
thousand subscribers that would be
awesome
you're at 92 now right yeah i was hoping
to get to 100 by the end of the year but
i know there are 100
people watching this that are willing to
subscribe we got taylor to uh
5k because i said in the video guys we
could give her a 5k we did that
uh i think it's only fair we get you to
100k if you get into 100 that would be
awesome we could do that so just
before you forget go down in the
description go and subscribe
like the video as well thank you so much
but if you're doing so well
in this pest control thing why would you
want to expand into other things it's
like graham just put out a video
saying that he doesn't want to buy real
estate anymore because his time is so
well spent
doing youtube so why would you choose to
go into these other fields
investing don't just make this youtube
sorry yeah
it's a great question on one it's fun to
do other things
but i think the biggest reason is you
know after i'd done a year i made 96
grand
i didn't spend anything i was very very
frugal early on so i was living on
you know maybe 10 grand a year if that
um
and i wanted to put it somewhere safe so
i reached out to a mentor
one of my buddies dads that had done
really well and said where should i put
this
and he said real estate so i started
looking at bigger pockets reading books
doing all of that
i looked at properties for a year and a
half before i did anything
but really it was because i now had this
money and i didn't want to blow it i
wanted to find a good place for it
but once i got that first deal and i was
getting those checks every month
it was just addicting like i wanted to
build an empire
and so that turned into the condo and
then the duplex and then duplex and
fourplex and
what i found with real estate is it's
really addicting
to buy and see that money coming in but
it also is just another cell
and so when i could find a property that
i could add value to
and purchase it and immediately raise
rents and now it's worth twenty thousand
dollars more
and then the next one's fifty thousand
and you know this last year i bought a
property that
within three months of raising rents it
was a million dollars
more than what i bought it for and so
it's just really
addicting so that's where the real
estate came in
um when it comes to youtube it's you'll
probably laugh at me but
i loved watching graham's channel like
fanboy for sure early on
but there was this sense of like i think
at the time you had
three or four rental properties and i
had
like 44. no it might have been like no
because it started i think i had five
it must have been fine maybe that's what
it was yeah but um
when i really started watching you i
think i had 30 or 40 units and i was
like
look at this guy like people love him
he's growing youtube channel it's super
cool
i've got like five times as many units
as he does i should
do that yeah and i really liked what you
did it was inspiring
to me um i learned a ton from it and so
that was originally why i wanted to do
it but the other reason is i had so many
sales reps and other people coming to me
and saying chandler will you mentor me
will you show me
and i figured if i put it all on youtube
then i could just say hey go watch these
10 videos
and then we can talk but then after
doing 10 videos
it's kind of addicting too yeah so then
i'm just kind of hooked on
trying to build that and they all work
together the youtube channel has found
me real estate deals
and it's found me power players for my
sales organization
and so they all feed off of each other
you know the more
people that i can find come work for me
the more my sales organization ticks the
more properties that i can buy
and it just kind of all worked together
so i just kind of scaled all of them
tell me about this place you made a
million dollars on okay what about that
so it's a 32 unit complex is that the
one that took you over 100
likes um it was okay yep and when i
purchased the property
rents on every unit averaged 496 dollars
and i knew that those properties could
be rented each unit
at 8.50 easy purely because i'd done it
a long time
it was an old owner that hadn't raised
rents in five or ten years
it was off market and so when i saw i
was like holy crap this is one of those
deals that you just dream about
so we put it together purchased the
property for 2.2 million dollars
with rents at 496 on average for each
unit
and they were already within three
months up to 850.
now that is a little bit of an
exaggeration because what i said is
if you stay we'll do them for 800 if you
leave we're going to fill them at 850
and a big chunk of people left
big chunk of people stayed um but we had
all the rents at either 800 or 850
within three months
so how did you find the deal so
i have become very connected in my area
i'm definitely not on the mls i think
everybody hops on the mls and they think
that's where it's at
i had a particular realtor that i
followed up with consistently
for like years because i knew he had a
bunch of older owners that he had helped
to purchase property and he had been
telling me for a long time like i've got
some of these i think they're going to
sell
and so just keeping that relationship
forever consistently following up
so that years down the road when it did
and i probably won't get into their
backstory but essentially some things
happened where they needed to get rid of
the property
and they hadn't added any value they
hadn't raised rents they hadn't done any
of that because
they had the property paid off and they
were cash flowing great for what they
had originally purchased it for
so i went in i did overpay slightly
um i think i bought it like a six cap
seven cap somewhere in there for what
their rents were
but i knew no doubt i could get them up
the only tricky part
was the bank was a little hesitant
because they didn't want to believe i
could raise them so much
so i talked the seller into giving me
ownership of three of the units
raising them to 850 so the bank was
chill with me then making the purchase
and then we raised yeah how did you
finance that it was it just did you have
a partner on this deal was it just you
it was all me okay yeah so thirty
percent down okay on that one
um how much did you buy why couldn't you
just buy it with just
30 down that seems reasonable to me what
do you mean the property couldn't
why why show the bank that you need to
raise the rents
because the numbers were so tight
that they were questioning my ability to
have it be profitable does that make
sense yeah
in idaho like out here they'd sell it
but in idaho they're requiring a certain
amount of cash flow
to lend on it especially with how young
i was yeah now granted i built a really
good relationship with the bank but it
was
edging on their number that they're
comfortable with um because it was
it wasn't cash flowing very much i think
on the
year like maybe a couple thousand
dollars a month
in cash flow for a 32 unit complex at
that price
okay um so being able to go in and and
bump the value
it doesn't make sense that you can
literally double dominance on a 32 unit
complex
okay so once i get proved to them hey i
did it with a couple units
so then i when i did it with all of them
the bank loved me and
i bought another property the 15 plex
this year from yeah
same thing but this time i didn't have
to argue with them at all they're just
like all right
so what happened with the tenants i bet
you were not very popular with the
tenants you've
been there for a long time this is why i
love
not managing my property yeah i have a
management company that deals with all
of that
but a strategy i've used that i think
has been great
is sending a letter that says hey we're
new management
you know obviously i think they put it
together taxes are higher expenses are
higher all of that
rents for this property will be 850
however if you choose to stay because we
want to take care of you
they're gonna be 800. now the people
that live in these these weren't
ghetto properties these were nice
properties everyone in there
knew they were getting a steal they also
know that if they go to look for
somewhere else to rent they're not going
to find anything for cheaper than that
800 and if they do it's going to be
divier than what they were living in so
does it suck for them yes but a lot of
these people had been there forever
knowing
that they were on a cash cow themselves
and so yeah like we got kickback for
sure but people were on a month-to-month
lease every
whoops every one of them was month to
month so when we did it wasn't like
we were you know ruining their lease or
making them leave early or doing
anything sketchy it was just hey
this is what they're going to be if you
want to go go if you want to stay we'll
give you a discount
that's the issue with uh la rent control
in california why it's so difficult is
because
there are so many properties exactly
like that in california
that you can't raise the rent more than
three percent every year
so the owner just screwed themselves
there but then you also can't
get rid of the tenants without uh just
cause
and just because you don't want them
there the rent slow you can't kick them
out either so you're kind of stuck with
this
so that's what i've the issue that i've
dealt with with with my rentals i raised
the rents maximum
every single year on all my properties
but i give the tenant a credit back
so that for them they said they have the
same thing over the year
but for me i get to show that at least
i'm raising rent so that if something
were to happen
and if i were to sell uh then
technically they are paying market rent
totally well and i think that's what i
love about
the area that i invest and obviously
there are pros and cons of everywhere
but
if you look and i don't want to share my
secrets everyone fled to idaho but
we've had just as good of appreciation
as california
as a matter of fact we've been top five
states the last couple years and so
when you've got a place that's getting
the appreciation property values are
going up but also
you can do whatever you want with rents
rents have exploded
everything has exploded so buying real
estate there not only are you getting
much beefier cash flow but now you've
got this huge value add and appreciation
that's happening naturally so yeah have
you had tenants in there not pay their
rent
yeah i mean i think i think everybody
deals with that but
overall no um i don't know if you've
seen this video
i had one really gnarly attention i love
that video
with jack put a b-roll of this there's a
guy sitting on a chair with his girl in
the lap
and they're getting evicted and it was a
wild video kevin's video
no it was kevin's but kevin reacted to
it
so what happened i invited kevin to go
out with
our sales guys to puerto rico
and i showed it to him because i had i'd
filmed it and it was sketch
but i have confrontation all the time on
the door so i was like let's just go see
we knew we were evicting him that week i
wanted to try and talk them out of it so
we didn't have to pay
to have them like taken out of the
property which we ended up having to do
anyways
so i just thought maybe i could sweet
taco maybe i could bribe them maybe i
could figure something to just get them
out
and i was a youtuber at that point so i
figured we'd see what would
happen i won't do anything like this
again because it was sketch
yeah and what happened is i went i
got them super calmed down i said look
maybe there's been some miscommunication
with my management company i'm the owner
i just want to make sure we're taking
care of you
would you mind coming out sitting down i
want to interview you and just learn
from the experience
and so he's like yeah i can do that but
i don't want to throw
your management company under the under
the bus like
he had a good relationship he just
didn't want to pay rent and he was on
drugs
so i talked him into coming out we sit
down we start
super calm and then things just get
crazy
i don't know if the drugs remind us what
happened because i remember watching
this episode start to finish
loving it i mean it was like a jerry
springer episode real estate edition
and i thought like i remember thinking
to myself
like you're crazy for doing this like
this guy could have
pulled out like a knife or like just
straight up has gotten up and
he's a big guy yeah and uh like just
could have pummeled you or just
oh and then just the dynamic between him
and the girl have you seen this
no i haven't pull up put b-roll up here
watch this now i'm sorry but but he's
got this girl on his lap
who's just like just agreeing with
everything he has to say like backing
him up she's like on his lap
like it's a middle school stuff like you
don't see adults doing this
this is what they do in middle school
did you have any backup
so i just had my videographer here's the
deal with door-to-door sales
i have people pull guns i have people
chase you down like
we deal with lots of stuff and we get
really good at calming people down and
so
i wasn't that sketch but it got to the
point where my videographer he'd never
been in a situation like that
and when i looked up and he was shaking
and his face was white i was like all
right we got to wrap this up
because i could tell and it got pretty
tense
i who aren't going to watch the video
just describe what happened
so essentially the girlfriend was ready
to say look we know we haven't paid rent
yeah
he was accusing us of a bunch of damage
to the property like you sold me a
garbage property they walked the
property all the windows had been broken
by them if
it had been flooded by them they were on
drugs so it was just a terrible
situation they totally trashed it if you
watch my other video you can see how
terrible
the property was it was just a bad
tenant i mean one out of every hundred
every couple years you get a bad tenant
and this one i think our screening has
gotten better since then this was
it was bad but essentially he gets fired
up
i don't know what happened and he was
trying to talk me
into letting him stay and fix all the
damage in the property that he had
caused
and so that we could be good and live
there for free
but then i asked him are you trying to
get free rent and he's like no i want to
fix this for you i
oh you remember yeah it just didn't make
any sense
he was just on drugs so what happened
though is
i bring it back i show my wife i'm hyped
because i'm like man everybody on
youtube is gonna love this yeah they did
and no she's like you're not posting
that that's not you
this is like it definitely came off
wrong
for me to film it and post it so i let
months go by
like not gonna did it i remember i
watched i didn't think it was that wrong
but then again i'm a landlord yeah so
tell me yeah i think
me if i would have posted it i think it
wouldn't have come off right but when
i'm in puerto rico with kevin i show him
and he's like
dude kevin of course yeah
you can ever not want to listen to kevin
you gotta freaking post it
and i was just like man i don't know
that i want to what if you
post it and just critique me like you
can have the footage you can do what you
want with it
so he posted it and he was brutally
honest
with it like he said chandler should
have done this different and so then i'm
like
it kevin kevin was it was a good video
it was critique it was good i feel like
i did a good job he
picked out some things i could have done
better um and so then i
responded to it and then people wanted
to see the whole video so then i posted
anyways
yeah but it was good because it was more
of a learning experience so
kevin doing that made it good to share
good for kevin
yeah but in the future don't listen to
everything
well if he wants to post it i was good
with it
next thing you know you're being sued by
uh
here's the deal kevin for me has been a
game changer for my channel i don't know
why when i had no subscribers he was
willing to fly out
look at my portfolio he's giving me tons
of advice yeah
you you know he's yeah of course he is
so it
uh no negative things to say about kevin
he's the freaking man
okay let's say one negative thing about
kevin one night we gotta all say
one bad thing what would be
um he needs to sleep more he's like
it's unhealthy how much is he sleeping i
thought he's sleeping enough
i so when we were in puerto rico we
would get up at seven
we would go and play until midnight and
then we'd hang out and talk till two and
then kevin would go and edit for three
hours
he'd get two hours of sleep and did that
every day yeah okay so but
i have always thought that those are
like short-term things like him and i
would take these trips and yeah he'd be
we'd be up until one or two
and then we'd go to bed but he'd be up
at like 5 30.
going on a run yeah like and then he
would come back with with a coffee at
like 6 30 in the morning
all right guys wow
but that's how he gets so much done he
drinks so much coffee and he doesn't get
a lot of sleep and
there's no way you can post five videos
a day and
be getting the right amount of sleep and
having two kids and a wife
and everything else he's got i really
want to
see behind the scenes of what he does
like i i the brutal honest
truth for like his life i'm not saying
he does anything but like
how he structures his day like what
that's really like for him
yeah i would i would love to get
singing the same thing of you i get dibs
on
maybe but i get dibs on on that video
idea that would be
if anyone wants like i i would love to
do a full day in life
actually if you have to follow him for
like a week too to get a real
real perspective i think the thing
that's crazy about kevin is i work with
hundreds of sales reps and i feel like
and i mean i'm sure you feel the same
way but you're pretty confident you can
outwork
most people and being around kevin
anytime i've done videos anytime i've
done
anything with him i feel outworked oh
yeah i can't and it's just like
he's not yeah yeah but yeah no with
kevin i know i can't
outwork him and i realized too with him
uh
if he sees someone else doing something
he's got a personal thing to go and do
better
yeah always it's so he'll see someone
and he'll be like all right i'm going to
find a way
and i know he's going to do it yeah
because he's got this determination
where he's not going to quit until he
does
and he's just the amount of time he puts
it like i can't compete anymore like
i've just given him the win on that like
kevin you win
you win well i think i remember you
and i can't say this is exact but yeah
when you blew up and i think
i don't know the timing but you had this
period where you were killing it above
anyone else in the finance space
and i feel like it was very much uh hold
my beer and he drinks up to five videos
a week
yep 100 it uh it's incredible yeah no
he's i
i've calculated because i watch
everyone's statistics on youtube like
everybody and he's going to outpace me
in views
uh in about 40 days or so maybe 45 days
you've done the math yeah and that's him
on the main channel his
channel against all three of my channels
seriously because of how much she's
churning out i'm just like
i've get i've accepted that and you've
got podcasts that are an hour and a half
long
yeah i know i've accepted that so kevin
you you win he is amazing for now
for now pretty soon he's going to take
my girlfriend take him down
i don't think that would go really well
it'll uh he'll take ramsey
take bailey kevin you can take that i'm
kidding
it's all in good fun i think i think
it's just a healthy there's always been
a healthy competition i think between me
and kevin
well it has to be cool yeah with the
time you guys i know being around kevin
raised my vision a ton yeah i'm sure you
felt the same way it's cool to be around
people like that because it makes you
think different and it's a good thing
definitely but let's go back to you talk
talk tonight a little bit more
about your first investment properties
did you pay cash for your first
rental so um it's funny because my real
first investment property
i had all this money in the bank and i
gave someone a loan they had crappy
credit they had
25 to put down on a property that i knew
they'd gotten under market value
and so i loaned them i think it was
ninety thousand dollars
at a nine and a half percent interest
rate and if they didn't refinance within
it was either a year and a half or two
years
the interest rate bumped two percent
every year um so they refinanced out
without
within two years and i got all that
money back so that was the first real
investment that i had done um after
doing that i think it was a year
after i bought a condo for seventy
thousand dollars in cash
that was the only other property i
bought cash and that was my biggest
mistake it was a good investment
property
but from then on out i am super anti
did you ever pull the equity out or did
you yeah so actually 10 31 that i think
i sold it for like 150 a couple years
later
and then moved that into one of the four
plexes that i bought
um so after that i bought a duplex
and then i kind of went ham in one year
i bought that duplex a duplex and a four
plex
and then the next year i bought an eight
plex and i think a couple four plexes
and then it just kind of went up from
there my first big one was that eight
plex
and then i did a 24 plex which was a big
jump
why are you doing multi-unit housing why
not single-family homes
um scalability and
here's the thing people stay away from
the bigger stuff because of financing
like 30-year fixed
lower down payment all of that stuff is
incredible
and so when you're starting that barrier
to entry it's awesome when you can get
great rates great terms
but when you can scale and you see it's
a value add opportunity then you've got
24
units that you can raise rents on you
can increase the value
crazy and i was making a lot of cash i
got in a point where
i couldn't find enough single family or
duplex or even four plexes to keep up
with the money that i had coming in and
so i had to look elsewhere
the 24 plex fell into my lab because it
was a seller finance deal
so that was really nice because then i
could get it for a lower down i could
get it on a 20-year fixed at pretty
decent interest rates
and still acquire you know a big chunk
of real estate with pretty decent
financing
how do you find the time for that stuff
yeah
um it's a great question i i was talking
to jack before i'm
like pretty overwhelmed with everything
i've got going on we have 550 sales reps
that are signed to work for me this
upcoming year the rentals i think the
biggest thing is that i have a
management company
so when purchasing rental properties i
have a bunch of relationships
that are feeding me deals but i only put
in a lot of time when it's like due
diligence
jump on the properties and i've got my
people trained to where they only bring
me deals if they're good deals
so i'm only analyzing the deals that are
pretty decent so i don't spend a ton of
time doing that
and then once i get them under contract
i throw them over to my management
company and i don't do anything i
probably spend one to two hours a month
just looking at the rents and making
sure that everything looks right when
they come in every month so
do they do the remodeling and everything
uh-huh they do
they didn't always but the guy that
manages all my properties he
just does my properties and then just a
couple others and he knows where i'm at
he knows what he can spend money on he
knows
all of that now i still have some checks
and balances that i look over every
month but he's incredible
and a lot of the renovations i do i'm
not like your renovation you did
i would never touch a renovation i know
when i do a renovation
didn't you make a video on on that i
think i made pretty sure you did
you made a video on it yeah i think you
did maybe
i think i know i thought about it for
sure it was either you i i know kevin
made a video on it
um let me see because i i remember
seeing a video on
that i told kevin to make a video on
that because i don't i've tried to never
dig on you super hard
let's see i've like this is on your
renovation yeah
uh i thought maybe it was you
uh
i know maybe not
there's someone who made a video telling
you they made one a lot of the
renovation which i
agreed with with them for for the market
they were coming from a different bar
i'm like yeah
in any other market other than la i
would agree with you yeah well the thing
is
for me it's all about the niche you pick
right i mean that was an
overwhelming renovation you did and you
kept finding more and more and more
with my renovations i make sure that i
know going in it's floors
it's paint it's lighting and maybe
cabinet stuff yep but it's all those
little fixes so i'm throwing five grand
to the unit
if that and it's good to roll and so he
knows all right this is what we're gonna
change this is what we can salvage he's
super thrifty super smart
so that it's gotten to the point where
he'll call and say hey i'm doing this
renovation this is what it's going to
cost this is what rents will be too and
we're good to go so are you ever nervous
that he's going to go and do this
on his own um not necessarily because he
has right
but he's making six figures because of
what he makes off of my properties and
even if he does it on his own he's still
gonna be managing
them on his own and he's like anybody he
wants to scale if he could have a
thousand units to manage
he would want that now when it gets to
that point do i have concerns that
maybe the quality of the way my
properties are taken care of will go
down
yeah but i've also built a relationship
where i try to really take care of him
and it's advantageous to both of us he
manages other properties and
a couple of those are his because he's
gotten the money to follow the same
model so
and what about your home living
situation while you were buying all
these investment properties did you ever
house hack were you living in like
duplexes or
did you just like all of a sudden start
making a bunch of money and then buy a
really nice home
so that's my biggest mistake looking
back
i just rented for a long time you know
the first couple years i was
even married um we were just renting a
place
and the reason for it is the school that
i went to required you to use
their housing um when i was single i
know that sounds dumb
but it's byu-idaho and they've got a
weird thing there so i
i couldn't buy a home and live in it and
attend
that university so you were attending
university while selling pest control
and everything
yeah making all that money mm-hmm yeah
did you
and you graduated uh no yeah
there we go just proud that's the right
choice happy as he's been right choice i
uh i have seven credits left to get my
accounting degree but
go back right now man it's it's for they
make you do an
internship and i didn't want to lie i've
had a count and say dude we'll just
check you off but
what's the point of getting a degree
when you just cheated on it and you
don't need it anyways like
yeah yeah it didn't make sense to me so
i could still go and finish but
i'm not going to was it i haven't really
i was gonna make a video about this i
i haven't like 100 all in but it's
yeah i haven't been taking classes was
it difficult to drop out
yeah just because it's a cultural thing
and your whole life
that's something you need to check off
like it's a guilt thing
and so i still have and and this is the
reality and in my job
i was making you know my net worth was
in the millions
i would still have people come and be
like hey so are you going to finish
school and that was their most important
question to ask me it wasn't about
anything else it was
about school so i'm over that now but
it uh that's why i hung on so long when
did you quit renting from the student
housing
um so once i got married the way that it
works is then you can get your own
housing but we had a bunch
of friends that i did the door-to-door
sales job with
so we rented an apartment where all of
us and our wives lived in the same place
so it was super fun that's funny rent
was super cheap
at that point we were buying rental
properties um i think i had like
15 20 units by that point but we were
paying
700 bucks a month in rent just living
close to our friends
um then we bought a house that i did all
kinds of funky stuff with i did like at
least to own
and then i sold it um made a ton of
money on that
and then moved into what we're living in
now so we bought a house for 420
thousand dollars two years ago
so yeah
and you are buying a new house or
building a new house
we heard you gave us a little taste of
what it is before the podcast but we had
to stop you so we could get more
information while we're live on the
podcast
tell us a bit about the the home you're
building so i feel like
everybody's gonna think i kind of lost
my shiz this year because
i bought two cars from the strad man and
we bought the 15 plex
and we're building our dream home um
the home is focused on my business so
8 000 square feet of it is home space
the rest is a basketball court a big
like locker room poker area
a um indoor swimming pool it's just kind
of like
is that is that for tax reasons you
could you could designate hey we got
plenty for the employees you told me
it's 18 000 square feet total
guys 18 so 10 000 over half of the home
is gonna be
business use basically yeah well and the
thing is is i spend a ton of money
like this month i rented a place for i
think we paid like
four or five grand to bring all of my
leadership
all these talented sales reps out to do
stuff with
and now i can do my house like it's set
up to be able to have
50 plus guys come and not just come but
like have a freaking blast
at the house so it it worked well for
what we were wanting to do but yeah for
taxes
we're gonna we're gonna work some things
for sure and you're building that place
uh-huh yeah here's the crazy thing and
hopefully you're okay with me
saw me listen tell me square footage on
this house what is it uh
20 about 2300. okay
lot size uh 8 500.
so my house is on four acres it'll be 18
000 square feet and it'll cost less than
this we'll be under 2.2 million
built how how much is land
because
18 000 square feet i i'm guessing that's
got to be about
two 200 a square foot on the low end to
build that i'm going to guess
the thing is so much so much as basement
space
okay can you really count that as square
footage though um technically or
yeah i mean it's it's space the thing is
is
and i don't know if you do basements out
here but basements are cheap like you
can do
nice basements i'll show you the
finishes but nice basement at like
85.95 a square foot so you save a ton of
money you've also got a basketball court
which is a bunch of dead space
you've got a pool which we did a
fiberglass pool which is super cool
which was pretty pretty inexpensive and
then just the space on that
um so yeah i'm calculating like
18 even even at a hundred dollars a
square foot
is gonna put you a one eight a hundred
dollars a square foot plus
land i'm guessing has to be 400
so 400 now now we're at 2-2
without any carrying costs or anything
how is it less how is it less than this
so what do you mean how's
like i think we'll be right at two to
one you see
a hundred dollars a square foot uh that
seems too
cheap that seems too cheap yeah i i
think wow
a lot of this is so much like you said
it's basement it's dead space yeah
if you like i can show you the bid on
everything if you guys want to see it
but even the basketball court i'm
thinking like okay sure we're not
putting like bathrooms and stuff like
that but still i'm guessing like the
foundation of that
the roof that that's got to be i don't
know
it's 50 grand 60 grand building is so
much cheaper really
there though yeah i mean even we're
still doing new build homes that are 4
000 square feet
like my brother just purchased one i
think he paid well like between three
and 350
for his 4 000 square foot new build home
so
it i mean yeah it is what it is i think
yeah the only thing you got to remember
that is including garage space
okay which is also extremely cheap okay
and in the garage
space i've got room i think do you want
to see the house plans yeah i do
okay these are the garages and the total
square footage in the garage is two
thousand
uh one hundred uh so eighteen thousand
square feet i mean
really you're okay you're like
technically you're less than that
because
the other thing and again the 18 000
square feet
sounds cool but under this two-car
garage we also did basement
but it's not necessarily finished it's
just framed in for storage
so that's another probably 1 000 square
feet here
under here we also did it but we're
putting in a locker room
for the guys to go to both so can you
screenshot whatever you're comfortable
yeah yeah so and i've done videos on all
of it all right so 18 000 square feet
but a lot of it isn't necessarily house
yeah i mean you've got a lot of garage
basketball court so
garages alone are we look 2100 you've
got another
thousand in the locker room which is
pretty simple space another thousand
just in storage area and then the
basketball court
is 52 feet by 30 something feet
so i do have a very important question
yeah are you extending an invitation
always to your playhouse yeah definitely
you guys come over oh we got so many
invitations we'll have to did you see
grant's
place yeah grant navarre yeah expect it
uh what's up
next week or something two weeks two
weeks
it's gonna be crazy it looks like a
manner his place looks like you would
like
you've seen in haunted house movies
where you go and there's like a big
mansion at the top of the hill that
you'd like don't want to spend the night
in it looks like that like it's that
it's massive
well here's the thing i've come to find
when we're building is you've got the
one dollar per square foot that you use
for rental properties
then you've got the four dollars per
square foot that people use for like
higher end spec homes and maybe even a
little bit of that
but then you've got ten dollars per
square foot for the stuff they're
bringing in from europe and all of that
like
we don't like that stuff we like the you
know
mix between modern and um contemporary
look and if you stay in that and you
don't spend on the lavish absurd stuff
you can get a ton of space that's
really nice super quality but then i see
people that are dropping
you know crazy money just on the
fixtures like the gold
fixtures or i mean you can go from
paying four dollars for one of those to
sixty dollars for one of those and i
think that's where on the higher end
homes people go
nuts no we're not doing cheap but like i
don't
think that's necessary for what we're
using it for does that make sense
yeah so so you're doing all this in a
year though so you bought
stradman's ferrari yeah the 458
and then you bought his corvette what
else are you going to buy from him
um did you try to buy anything else
no i here's the thing i was gonna talk
to you about this yeah
um so with the cars they're kind of
unique i got into a situation where i
had a lot of cash flow that we'd been
saving up for the home
from the properties and my goal has
always been to live within my cash flow
so
super frugal early on but then when i
started buying these bigger properties
i was having a lot of cash flow come in
it was kind of building up because it
took us a while to get to
purchasing our home so we had that money
however
after purchasing the c8 corvette and i
had launched my course
i saw how many people that brought over
and
i really wanted to buy another supercar
it helped my channel
it helped my sales business i let all my
guys drive it like it was a cool fun
thing
and so i reached out to the strad man
and was like hey i think i want to buy
another one what do you think
and the ferrari 458 was one of the cars
that i wanted
well he goes and buys it so when he buys
it i'm like dude you bought the car i
really want
would you ever sell that one to me as
well and he had different plans for it
so he said
i'll let you know if i do well he
reaches back out and says
a month later i'm going to sell it do
you want it
and i wanted it but i was also you know
i'd spent a lot of money through that
portion i was kind of
hesitant the c8 was the first car i
bought so i kind of pitched it like
i'll buy it at the price you bought it
and you've already put 3000 miles on
but would you be willing to pitch my
real estate investing course because i'd
done
pretty well on that course and he agreed
to it he checked out the course
looked through it he was happy with it
and he said let's do it so
by purchasing the ferrari yes i could
afford it but then i essentially
got it for free because of what we made
that's really smart
did you make a video have you ever made
a video about how you got the ferrari
for free
no i feel like you're milking all this
out of me because i was hesitant to
share
course sales i don't i love the course i
feel like it brings huge
value yeah but i've always given
everything
away for free and i've tried you know
what i mean like it was uncomfortable to
be like this time
which i made guys i'm gonna link it down
below so now you have to explain
it so i'll link it down below but in
return you have to show how much money
it's making because i'm curious
okay so um up to this point i've made
215 000 okay off of the course
and the majority of that came in after
the ferrari porch
purchased um so yeah it's done
it's done really well i think the other
thing that is cool about the ferrari
purchase and this is something the strad
man taught me
but because i have that's my fifth
vehicle yeah i
only use it for youtube like that's it
i'm always recording when i use it
so that particular car i can write off
as a prop
oh yeah which means i can write off the
entire car year one
stradman has been trying to talk me into
a ford gt
and i really need a cool car to park in
that garage space
in las vegas because there is going to
be a car did you watch my uh
house tour video yeah i did okay so that
you had that garage space
in the office it it won't be as cool as
stradman's car on the wall but it'll be
pretty free i know
um i was thinking the ford gt would be a
car and
and this would be would you get an older
one or like newer 2005-2000
um let me know what you guys think uh
this is the first time i've ever brought
it up
my my fear is being a guru that i am
this guy who always talks about being so
frugal
and uh you know i'm still using those
towels over the lights
instead of diffusers still doing
everything on my own same camera i
bought a used camera on ebay
uh and that's like for for the for the
vegas place
but uh and then you have this expensive
car in the background so i don't know if
it would be too
like hypocritical to do something like
that well this is one of the things that
is really difficult and i think we've
both been in this situation and i've
kind of made the jump off the cliff
where
i've been frugal my whole life i've been
very smart that's how i was able to
purchase the real estate
i was but when you set a goal and you
say hey you know
if my passive income can afford it and
your active income gets to a point where
you're making a ton there too
like what's the point of money if you're
not going to spend it and
we're both in businesses where cars do
move the needle and for you it might be
different
you're branded as the frugal guy but
it's opened
a ton of doors for me in my sales
business
um and that's a that's a different thing
for me
but when they can take the c8 like we'll
go to activities and i'll have 50 guys
go and test drive the c8 like
that's huge because they're sharing on
instagram they're sharing it with their
friends
that's a great opportunity for me to
find good leaders good sales reps
other good things so with that with
youtube with everything else for me
i felt like it definitely made sense but
only because i also really wanted one of
those cars
yeah i don't know i feel for me it would
almost work against me
to do something like that because then i
then then the guy
changed yeah then the guy makes a whole
bunch of money and then starts
nice nice places in vegas and a car and
stuff like that he already did the nice
place in vegas
but that's cheap that's because it's
cheaper than this
and because of how much money that saved
the car is something that
will hold its value will go up i i i'm
guessing it'll go up about five percent
a year
um but then i'm tying up all this money
in a car
that could be invested or doing
something else yeah
diversification you've got to invest in
all right yeah
i don't and it's hard and i it's funny
this is a video i did make because i
feel like
for sure you're a little pinned like
your main interview is youtube and you
branded yourself in a certain way
and that's it's hard to to work around
that but at the same time
um people follow you because you're
relatable
but i think people are hoping that the
principles you teach them will help them
to acquire
their dreams maybe i'm wrong but i don't
think they want to be
60 years old and have none of the things
that they've
envisioned or wanted their whole life by
taking all right
am i wrong in saying that uh i mean you
could ask the viewers
comment down below let me know what you
think but i'm a i think it's kind of
funny to be that like that
that one day be that like old guy who's
constantly like with all the
money in the bag and be like are you
doing spending money what are you doing
like
i find that funny like uh my i i love
this uh
uh my buddy brandon's grandpa was like
103 years old
completely self-made and he must he must
have had like 200 million dollars with
the real estate
on beverly boulevard in los angeles
right by the beverly center this is like
prime real estate he owned the entire
block that he just accumulated over a
decade after decade of j
and he would sit there and i love this
he brandon said he was the cheapest guy
in the world
he would i'm not advocating doing this
but when you'd go to the restaurants
he would take like the salt and pepper
uh little packets
and stuff them and take them home
because he just he want he always wanted
to get a deal
and he always wanted to feel like if
he's going out to restaurant spending
money he wants to get something
back for that uh but apparently do you
really want to be that guy
but i think it's funny wait the story
continues but apparently
it got so bad that uh his daughter
so brandon's mom would have to check his
pockets
before they left because he would take
the silverware
because he's just silver yes because
because i know i'm not advocating this i
thought it was funny
that was funny but his mentality was
that i'm over spending on this food here
it's just too expensive
so if i take something back then it's
even and this guy
this guy was worth hundreds of millions
of dollars and the best part of all of
this is he would still go into his
office every single day
even though he didn't need the money for
no reason all he would go to his eye
he'd like to be in the office every day
and he put his office right next to the
vending machine and
his favorite time of the day was when
someone put in a dollar in the vending
machine
they get a soda immediately as the
person lefty go out with a key
open up the vending machine take the
dollars
let's sit down that was he loved it
funny
like i look at that
i've always related to that in some way
or another just like oh
taking the dollar get the dollar like i
just something about that yeah
no totally and i i have two i think
a lot of people that are successful can
relate to that
the thing i recognized is and this can
be turned back on youtube but
the way you do anything is the way you
do everything and
i really wanted to have or evolve into
the mindset
of there's enough to go around yeah
and making this transition it's
interesting because it's helped me
treat my employees better it's helped me
take care of my people better like
when you make that shift that their
money is always going to be coming in
i feel like yeah it's helped me to get
more things and those things that
motivated me but it told me to share
those things more too
yeah and people like that i've i've very
rarely seen them be
generous people am i wrong in saying
that yeah no
you're right on that and so i think they
go hand in hand and i'll tell you my
favorite part about the ca corvette is
when i toss the keys to a guy and i'm
like
go do whatever you want if and obviously
i hope no one ever crashes it but if
they scrape it if they do whatever like
that's why i got the car is to give
people that experience to help them get
that vision to help them see like
holy cow i love cars i love this i know
you love cars
and having something that you can work
towards and you do it the right way by
creating passive income first that
you're motivated to do that
i feel like that's huge it's a big
motivator yeah
i don't disagree with that at all i
guess my biggest concern is is uh
is being that guy who made money and
then started
spending it on frivolous stuff yeah well
and i will be the first one to say
i have struggled you can look at my
instagram my brother
gives me a hard time about it when you
get a car people love cool cars
and then it's hard to not include them
in your videos because
you instantly turn into tai lopez
because people there's this
big majority of people that want to see
it and they want to experience it and
that's really fun
but then i've done some videos where i'm
like oh
that isn't that isn't the direction i
want to go so i see that being a bad
thing too i don't know i i look up to
people like dave ramsey and i'm like
what what would dave ramsey do
and he's mentioned before that he has a
few cars in the six-figure mark
we've never seen him ever talk about one
of
like which cars he has or driving his
cars or so i look at that and i'm like
that's a good example
of kind of where to go look at dave
ramsey what is he doing
he's respectable so it's maybe i i don't
know
i don't know see if i had to pick idols
he wouldn't make top 10 for sure
for me for me dave ramsey would be top
three other than dave ramsey who would
be yours
joe rogan dr phil
[Applause]
i love all those guys yeah i i love dr
phil i really do i look at his career
uh joe joe rogan i think is the coolest
of all of them
judge judy's had one of the best careers
uh
dr phil i love his platform
dave ramsey i like his just he's very
grounded
yeah so it's really just good core
principles sticks with them
yeah yeah yeah i like you know what i
like and really respect with dave ramsey
that he doesn't waver that he has his
way
that's it he's never changed his course
he's very con convicted of one thing
and that's what works for him yeah see
it's interesting because
i've got all these people that i love
learning the way they invest
i love the way they view money but i
don't think any of them would make
that for me i think for me it's like my
dad my grandpa
all the people in the way that they
raised their family and the way that
they taught their kids and
and i think that is an evolution just
because i have kids now where
it's like man that is most important to
me is the way my kids view me
but it's hard that's how do things
change with kids
um how old are you now
so i'm i just turned 30. wow we're the
same age
yeah how old are your kids so three and
one i can see i can't imagine having a
kid
i can't like that seems so like like
bailey has been
er macy's the one who deals with bailey
but has been
like there's a puppy and then i can't
imagine like
that times 50 or whatever i don't know
yeah well i think it just
changes everything because everything i
do
everything i do your kids are watching
and that's affecting
who they're becoming so i don't know
that's what
like i love what i've done on the
financial side of things but the end of
the day
how they turn out is more important than
anything else and
the only people that i follow their role
models is because of
they've had that impact on me you know
so i don't know
i i think the biggest difference is just
your time
i never have a minute in the day where
i'm not thinking all right this has got
to be good because it could be time with
my kids
that makes sense yeah so okay yeah
speaking of dave ramsey i am so curious
how much debt do you have um
a good amount i think like
seven or eight million i got it all
ready on a spreadsheet
so we could talk about it it's not as
bad as what i thought though i thought
it was going
higher you're gonna record graham stefan
reacts to my investment portfolio right
yes
if you guys want to see that that it
that will be on your channel it will
yeah we'll link down below link down
below in the description yeah all right
well and it's interesting because when
you buy real estate over a period of
time and all these properties i'm
putting 25 to 30 percent down
when they're value add properties you're
adding a bunch of
equity into the properties really
quickly so um
the debt isn't nearly as scary compared
to what you owe because you've been
paying them off for one but
you also have added value by increasing
rents
so um geez that sounds scary though
seven to eight million
no it's sorry i blanked out for a second
my mind is going somewhere
totally unrelated to anything now going
back to the debt um
so jack just say 7 million seems like a
lot
seven million seems like a lot yeah it
it is but at the same time i've got so
much equity in those properties
that it it isn't yeah what's the total
worth on that
so when i'm 14 yeah
i think i'm like 13 14 million in
properties
so about 50 it's not that's not that bad
mine my total debt with that i think
minus four
um and the properties i think are worth
eight and a half something like that
nine
so it's it's less than fifty percent so
i don't i don't think your debt is bad
at all for what for what you own no
especially
i mean i always keep six months reserves
minimum and a lot of times i'm pushing a
year on that so
like what's the worst that can happen
like even if something terrible happens
you lower rents and you're still cash
flowing you're still able to pay your
mortgage so
i think people just stress on debt way
too much that's a big reason i'm not a
dave ramsey fan is i feel like that's an
incredible tool used properly
i also understand why when people use it
incorrectly it can really
bite them i want to know what your total
debt payment is every month my guess
is seven mil you're probably paying
about
34 thousand a month i'm gonna guess
right
you're good yeah i think when i did the
math it's like 37. oh
i'm close yeah that's a joke it's gonna
say 37.
yeah so uh it's good and with those
numbers i didn't include the um
storage units well actually no i think i
did how much does your storage unit make
so we're still figuring that out but i
think we'll have uh
probably like 12 percent cash on cash
once we get the numbers where they
should be when we bought it
i think it was only like a eight or nine
because we've got some work to do on
getting them up but again old owner
hadn't raised rents in forever
yeah a lot of value ad opportunities
those are the deals i love when i
see them i know i don't really have to
do a lot of work but i know they're way
undervalued because an older owners have
had them
forever and just hasn't raised rents and
so and
what's your goal with all of this like
how many units are you
trying to buy what's do you have any
plan if i'm
honest um i hit like a weird point
because it was always 100
units was this thing where i thought i'd
have all the cash flow in the world
it's become addicting i love finding
good deals i love negotiating them i
love to do
diligence on them that is the one thing
that's never felt like work
like finding and buying real estate is
just a passion it's fun it's a hobby
my wife makes fun of me because excel is
my hangout like i like
running the numbers on properties so um
i've let off the gas a little bit
because we had a big year
but i'm sure i'll always buy property
um i'm trying to figure out what my next
goal is if i wanna say
i'm gonna do a thousand units or why not
do stocks
i've been doing with stocks this year
it's been so much more relaxing
so it's so funny i was yeah i went over
to kevin's place
today for like two three hours and he's
definitely on that stock train for sure
um i think i've spent so much time
getting good at real estate
that again it's a hobby even if you came
and said hey you could make the same
amount
well that's not true if i could make the
same amount i do stocks if i knew it and
there was no risk
i just feel like risk is really low
because i know my market really well
i know my deals really well i know what
goes into it
um but it's also like to be safe with
diversification
yeah i honestly should transition and
that's why i brought it up with kevin is
and when i watched your kevin o'leary
thing yeah and he kind of blasted you a
little bit
i was like freak you know i've always
especially rich dad poor dad like don't
diversify right that's what i've lived
by but i do think
in the next year or two i need to i'll
tell you my own personal experience i've
invested
besides buying the vegas place in this
place everything else into stocks
best decision ever just like split
between index funds and just i got those
individual stocks
happen to do well but it's been nice
yeah it's so nice just to be able
and i i have a thing every morning i go
in and i buy
the s p 500 every morning it's just like
my
my thing in the morning i love going in
there click and buy
and just it's off and it's done and then
it's been a good market
yeah it has but i mean i've been true
and if it was a bad market you could
still rent out your places since they're
here in l.a yes true
that that's the budding i was gonna ask
your personality yeah with what you've
told me about
you know the old man it has to hurt your
soul if you see yourself lose a hundred
grand
like and you see it dip does that not
affect you or uh no there was one day
there's one day in the market i think i
was down 60 grand
uh and uh you told me yeah i showed ya
the hard part for me was that uh and and
by the way this is like down 60 but i
was still
up so it wasn't like down money but i
was up and then down 60.
and i remember thinking to myself like
how many times where i was so
like i didn't order the avocado i didn't
get the double meat at chipotle
i got the smaller appetizer because i
didn't want to spend the extra like
three dollars
and i'm like they're 60 grand gone how
many times could i have done that so
that was that was what was so hard for
me
uh but now it doesn't bother me i think
in the beginning when i was really going
heavy into it
um it just it took some getting used to
but now any swings
of plus or minus like 30 40 50 grand
just
doesn't mean it's just it doesn't matter
anymore when i can it's the same with
real estate
early on when you have a bad eviction
you've got to go and it hurts really bad
and you're questioning yourself and now
money comes and money goes and it just
is what it is but
i don't know i love personal ownership i
love the empire aspect but you can get
both
mine but you could get both yeah and i
should like i know just
try it i would take with with the amount
of money you're making take 500 grand or
a mill
put one million in just a broad index
fund and leave it
see how nice that is you invested in
stocks no no
i did one year when i didn't know what i
was doing i have eight grand in an ira
you got your four free stocks for free
stocks it's time for robin hood
m1 finance yeah yeah i need to do that i
know
that's a good thing to make money on
youtube and i don't do it yeah
but you should try like my goal
this well in the next like six months is
i want enough in the stock market
no i'm almost i won enough the stock
market where it equals the amount of
debt i have in the real estate so four
million in debt i want four million in
the stock market interest that's that's
my next
and then how much in bitcoin i should do
that's another thing i i feel like i
should andre
jake has been telling me non-stop to put
money in bitcoin since like
10k well i heard what like tony robbins
was saying
it should be at least ten percent of
your portfolio i think ten percent is
too much i mean
andre says one percent and i hated his
advice and it's done me well
really well yeah especially the last
month or two right
i don't yeah i i wouldn't say there's
any downside in putting
one percent of your entire net worth in
bitcoin
yeah i don't think there's i mean worst
case you lose one percent
but it's never going to go down 100 it's
never going to be worth nothing that's
all i think it's always going to be
some sort of value yeah so you're not
going to lose the worst case you go from
one percent to like
a quarter of a percent like worst case
but yeah oh i was just going to say with
the stock market bitcoin any of that
stuff when i see it's like this
i get major anxiety to put money into
something that's like this
and so yeah but real estate has been
like this this year too yeah
i think i understand it though all that
stuff and and that really is my problem
is
it's going to take me investing time
into it i just don't have the time i
don't want to put in the time i know i
should put in the time but
yeah i think that's right i think i
think it would do you well to start
buying into it
just do it a little little by little and
it'll make you feel good
so yeah so now we got to find the click
bait for the title here
how much how much did you uh make how
much how much do you make every month
what is this
you run a really tight ship this is way
more organized than mine mine i just do
like
one bank account what bank is that yeah
um
i don't really want it's a local credit
union i don't want people knowing
a small bank i use but um so essentially
you can see the mortgages going out and
you can see the rents coming in you can
even go back a couple months and see the
consistency of them
some have good somehow bad but why do
some of these have a lot of cash in them
and others don't
um that doesn't have a whole lot of
rhyme or reason to it
essentially when they get pretty big i
just pull it i always keep at least that
six months reserves for the units in
there
got it at least i try to does that make
sense yeah this is a higher interest
rate savings account
so i'll move everything out of the llc's
and put them here because i'm getting
just shy of two percent
on that money wow how are you getting
two percent on that
so here's the thing everything i do i
use local credit unions that i built
relationships with for years
so my credit cards my mortgages
that's why i can get such good rates on
commercial loans like my last loan i got
10-year fixed 25-year am with a 25
down at a 3.5 interest rate wow now in a
commercial property
yeah and it's because i do everything
through them so i just went in and i
said
here's the deal like i need a higher
interest rate on the money that's
sitting there
i've kept everything with you guys i
shopped it out with everybody
and then i got them to go and you're a
big fish there you do that in la people
would laugh
you bring that amount to banks they
won't even care you have to have like
five mil
plus yeah for them to even consider like
having like a private banking
relationship or anything
and that's why my biggest and i push
this on my channel hard if you're in an
area
find your small local credit unions
because they're willing to talk to you
they're willing and they weren't early
on
but once i had three four or five
mortgages with them once i had pretty
decent deposits with them
then i'd built those relationships and
now i know all the people that make
those
i should just give you my money you take
half a percent and then i take the other
one and a half
accounts these are fun we should all you
start a syndicate
seriously i guarantee two percent like
everyone would give you their money at
half a percent
so you could give them back one and a
half yeah and i'm sure i'd get like
there's got to be something illegal
about that
yeah and i'm sure a big a big portion of
it is
all the business they're they're
watching that stuff for sure but
not a bad business side that's the thing
though is people
there are other ways right now the
market's harder and i i
guarantee this will drop because of
what's gone on i just had it locked in
for a year
yeah so so we have to know though
an amount for clickbait yeah what is
your total monthly
revenue gross what is your gross revenue
from rental properties so um
i didn't run the gross i ran after all
of my expenses
and maintenance that's not clickbait and
that's not clickbait we need gross
i can i can do the math really quick and
get it but
we need to we need the graphs yeah just
or or honestly just round it off let's
just like
round it off right now we'll cut this
part out just be like
i'm gonna estimate it's around you know
it's about
got it because we want to put a hundred
thousand a month so that's the goal
how'd you like your sparkling water
grams it's really good i liked it a lot
isn't it good yeah
zero calories i was laughing at this
thing i posted on my story
190 000 ceiling fans recalled because
the blades detached
and fly off and then my capture was if
you thought 2020 couldn't possibly get
anywhere
that's so gnarly
i saw that it was like jeez
crazy it's wild
imagine like sitting down like watching
the simpsons like with your family and
just a
blade from the ceiling just sticks right
next to your head like
final destination have you seen that
movie no i've not oh final the great
movie
it's basically that they they cheat the
d
word when you when you pass away they
cheated that d word
and then the d word comes and tries to
get them so you can't escape
oh that's fascinating yeah so yeah one
guy had a premonition
of something avoided it so he could
still live
and then they find these grotesque ways
to
get everybody off one by one and so
blades splitting
the fan like these random acts to anyway
guys shout out final destination think
of that oh we need to get it going come
on
come on there has to be something so so
he's adding up he's adding up his gross
rents and we're telling him we need to
put 100
he gets 95 500 a month that's legit
what it is though that's his gross 100k
you had to find a way to get another 4
500 in there 45 pounds get another one
buy another unit we're putting a hundred
grand you get 100
i helped three different people buy
properties that would have put it over
but i passed them off to my sales reps
and then jack
all right there you go 100 000 really
it's 95.5 but
we're going to call it 100 rounded off
you make 4 000 elsewhere
we're sure of it yeah it's coming
somewhere yeah wow
yeah are you going to help jack find a
place yeah we got to talk about this
because
we had jack dougherty on the podcast and
he said that you helped him
find an investment property you walked
him through basically everything
he gets to use your property manager
manager same lender that you use
so i reached out to you and i asked if
you could do something
with me because i want to get into real
estate but it's difficult for me because
i don't have very much time to figure
out the new la market or las vegas
market
and i knew what you did with jack so i
was wondering you know if you'd do the
same thing for me and you agree
i i did it that's dangerous because if
anything happens
we're on the podcast here so that's
what's so that's the danger
and same with jack so and i think he
talked about on your podcast he'd had
negative experiences before
it the reason i don't ever want to do
like partnerships or anything like that
is
i want people to understand what they're
doing and i want them to make the
decision that
hey it's right deal i don't want anna i
don't want to take money from it
and that's why i can't do this for
everyone so it's
i'm starting to set a precedent and a
lot of these deals are deals i would buy
i would want to dude
once and everyone else is going to come
out
i think i know exactly what i want
though uh maximum profitability
minimal uh risk yeah that's what i'm
learning that's whatever it is that
sounds good
that sounds good yeah so we're we are
gonna
i am going to help you pull it off i
gotta figure out
how i'm gonna do it moving forward just
because i can't like the jack one
stressed me out because i knew it's a
big audience
and with my audience i push 10 cash on
cash return it's got to be that
kevin gives me a hard time like that's
hard to find that's a really good deal
and it sucks to hand that over
especially when i didn't make any money
on it but
it it comes around so i did tell you i'd
do it we'll we'll find a way
no promises on how quickly i think in
the next couple no rush
okay no rush a couple of months that's
jack has a few days
max
but yeah i'm extremely excited to get
into
you know investment properties and i
will keep you guys updated with the
journey
so everyone will know what's going on
very excited and very grateful for this
opportunity yeah
definitely and we are going to make sure
that you know your stuff so that when we
do find a good property
i want to see you hyped because you've
done your research and you know like
it's
good yeah i just have to understand but
give
give jack that one okay that's fine give
jack your uh program give jack your
program so he could go through it and
then learn from that and actually i want
to see it too
okay so i want your feedback too
the thing about it is there's so much in
real estate investing and i'm
consistently adding to it but
i really tried to make it so that people
knew everything they needed to know to
find properties
to build relationships to do due
diligence to know what a good deal is
and to know how to finish and get that i
want to watch it um and the reason why
is because
i've wanted to do a real estate
investing course
for years but i got so burnt out after
doing the youtube course
it's sent to me yeah and i i
i couldn't do it because i realized that
it's not just like how to buy
real estate but then how to how to
negotiate and then how to do your
inspections and then how to get a loan
and how to shop the loan around how do
you find tenants and
and it became like one thing i had to do
two other points
talk about it and then two other points
and then two it kept forking and fork
and
i then i'm like i got this project for
like years yeah
and by the time i make it then people
are gonna want something like new
so i i've given up on that for now it's
super overwhelming i'm curious to see
what you think
about mine i think what is hard is i
love
giving stuff away from free but there's
value when you spend money and when you
invest in yourself and do that but
i've wanted to keep it at a price point
that's why it's out where it's at
um but i'm always going to feel like
there's more especially when people
start thinking about 1031 exchanges when
they start thinking about cost
segregation oh my gosh and then that's
yeah
all of that other stuff and i've added
videos with that i'm always going to be
adding because when you get into bigger
multi-family all of that i feel like
they're going to want to know about that
all right so we'll watch it send it send
it over
we'll link it we'll link it down below
but uh jack you will be the uh
the decider on this one if you like it
if you don't like it we gotta blast it
that sounds good yeah and if you get a
bad deal too
what you could do is sit down with them
sit down
yeah yeah but we've been recording now
for
an hour and 30 minutes all right thank
you so much so much thank you
this is amazing meeting you we've been
talking on the phone it's good to
finally see your face
thank you for coming on yeah we pulled
strings to get you on today
yeah so i'm really glad like last minute
you agreed to come on and and talk to us
so it was like
last episode of the year yeah definitely
and you need to know look up to you a
ton like love your channel okay thanks
for
this this is awesome this is fun thank
you for having me yeah what's your
credit score
um i looked it up i knew you would ask i
think i'm 789.
good it is how much did it just drop
because the big purchase yeah so
how many credit cards you have uh
six okay yeah cool that's pretty good
that's good
all right cool so thank you guys so much
for watching we really appreciate it
make sure to subscribe
uh hit the like button get your four
free stocks uh your information is down
below in the description
we gotta get you to 100k yeah we need
listen if you're watching this right now
if
everybody who got to this point just
goes and subscribes it's a perfect point
to go and do this before you forget
go and subscribe we'll get you to 100k
awesome i had a goal by 2021 and i'm
just so oh
let's do it yeah uh oh no no no we're
going to be posting this on sunday it's
not going to happen by then
are you kidding me yeah
i thought we had a few extra days yeah
destroy the like button cool thanks guys
for watching and until next time
thanks guys
you know how to do the intros um i watch
it but i'll probably crack under
pressure you can't get me
what does it work how much money we've
made 30 no okay
33rd episode yeah yep so you're gonna
say welcome to the 33rd
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
introduce yourself
and then say so far the podcast has made
maybe like 20
sorry i'm going to write it down 28 9
40.
29 28 9 40. welcome to the 33rd
episode of the ice ever
there you go welcome to the 33rd ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
so far you have made twenty eight
thousand nine hundred and forty dollars
is that right that is absolutely good
yeah once more once more okay take the
energy 20
and then say your name so higher or not
20 more energy outdoor voice welcome to
the 33rd ever episode of the iced coffee
hour
my name is uh chandler david smith am i
allowed to start with what's up or
what's going on whatever you want
whatever you want yeah go for it go
what's going on guys welcome to the
33rd
you